well welcome everybody it was quite a
long night with the State of the Union
delivered by Joe Biden it has led to
this cone of hair sticking out the side
of my head and sometimes it is even
stronger than gravity so I apologize to
the extent that it is distracting but we
have to talk about this Joe Biden State
of the Union my expectations were that
Joe Biden would probably mention a few
new policy ideas which he did but I did
not expect him to go at Republicans so
directly and so brutally and Republicans
are so easily triggered that the guess
was they would be somewhat triggered by
Joe Biden but the degree to which last
night's State of the Union Address made
these right Wingers explode even during
the event shouting things at Joe Biden
and humiliating themselves in so many
different ways it even surprised me now
Joe Biden called for a billionaire
attack
he called for a larger tax on stock
BuyBacks saying quadruple it presumably
from one to four percent he announced a
plan to expand the thirty five dollar a
month uh cost cap on insulin Beyond just
individuals on Medicare but what really
got them in a tizzy was when he really
laid an incredible trap for Republicans
where Joe Biden said you know some
Republicans want a sunset Social
Security and Medicare
and they started yelling no no no you're
a liar to which Joe Biden said well
great I guess that means that subject is
off the table and we don't even have to
talk about it anymore take a look at
this take the economy hostage I get it
unless I agree to the recognized Clans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
hahaha
let me give you
[Music]
a lovers
and there you see Marjorie Taylor green
very much channeling Cruella Deville
screaming and pointing at Joe Biden the
copy of The Proposal
these Congress doesn't
I'm glad to see you now I tell you I
enjoy conversion
you know how amazing if Congress doesn't
keep the programs the way they are
they'd go away other Republicans say I'm
not saying it's a majority of you I
don't even think it's even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look folks
the ideas
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't
respond
folks
so folks as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now
[Applause]
so listen this is this is really one of
the greatest traps that I've seen set in
this sort of live format it would be a
good trap no matter what but to carry it
out live in front of an audience is is
quite stunning now it is a subject of
debate whether Republicans really are
open to Sun setting Social Security and
Medicare the idea of sun setting is
something that was popularized by Rick
Scott senator from Florida
which is all legislation sunsets after
five years and then we decide do we want
to bring it back or not and he didn't
name Social Security and Medicare but he
also didn't say Social Security and
Medicare were exempt so a reasonable
interpretation would be they are open to
Sun setting Social Security and Medicare
although maybe their intention is to
keep them as they are but debate aside
Republicans flipping out in this way now
puts them in a corner where they can't
seriously they can't in a serious manner
come forward and say well let's debate
whether we want to cut Social Security
in Medicare because here they seemed
vehement in uh their opposition to that
so an absolutely brilliant trap really a
master class in exposing these
Hypocrites and the event also exposed by
the way that Kevin McCarthy has no power
Kevin McCarthy trying to shush members
who were screaming during the State of
the Union Address they ignored him uh
here is one moment during which Marjorie
Taylor green screams out and if you're
watching you will see Kevin McCarthy
shaking his head no and trying to shush
her with very little success investing
American innovation and Industry will
Define the future that China intends to
be dominating
investing in our alliances and there you
see McCarthy shake his head and go shhh
and he had no control no control over
his party uh here is just one of many
images of Marjorie Taylor green just
screaming at the top of her lungs and
completely humiliating herself in every
way when the topic of fentanyl came up
which is increasingly being pronounced
fentanyl I still don't know why they
pronounce it this way but in any case
you know what what I'm talking about
when Joe Biden brought up the deaths as
a result of Fentanyl
um a Heckler believed to be Matt Gates
started screaming it's your fault it's
your fault and this was another
opportunity for Republicans to debase
themselves fentanyl is killing more than
70 000 Americans a year
[Music]
[Applause]
you got it
your car
so you hear combinations of it's your
fault it's the Border Etc the idea being
that weak On the Border Joe Biden is
letting fentanyl in now of course as
we've been covering since Joe Biden
became president the difference is in
Border policy between Donald Trump and
Joe Biden are extraordinarily subtle
really the change is that as the
pandemic eased movement of people
increased again but this is another one
of these baseless tropes there were all
of the standard sort of uh elements of
Pomp and Circumstance during the State
of the Union uh one of the moments was
when
um Joe Biden actually
um recognized I guess we would say
Brandon say the 26 year old who disarmed
the Monterey Park gunman and these
moments are common in state of the union
addresses join us tonight is Brandon
saying a 26 year old hero Brandon put
his call his dreams on hold to be at his
mom's side
when she was dying from cancer
Brandon
Brandon now works at the dance studio
started by his grandparents
two weeks ago
during the Lunar New Year celebrations
you heard the studio door closed and you
saw a man standing there pointing
semi-automatic pistol atom
he thought he was going to die
but he thought about the people inside
and that instant he found the courage to
act and Wrestled a semi-automatic pistol
away from the gunman who had already
killed 11 people in another Dance Studio
11.
he saved lives
it's time we do the same band assault
weapons now
ban them now
and there is Lauren bobert of course
shaking her head probably upset that
Brandon say wasn't armed himself in
order to stop that gunman
um another Moment Like This Joe Biden
recognizing Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul
Pelosi of course who was attacked
brutally and viciously uh by a what do
we even call call the guy a radicalized
conspiracy theorist of sorts and it is
actually really good to see that 82 year
old Paul Pelosi seems to be recovering
well two years our democracy has been
threatened and attacked put at risk
put to the test In This Very Room on
January the 6th and then just a few
months ago
an unhinged big lie
a sale and Unleashed a political
violence the home of the Dead Speaker of
the House Representatives
using the very same language the
insurrectionists used as they stalked
these halls and chanted on January 6th
here tonight in this chamber is a man
who Bears the scars of that brutal
attack
but it's as tough and as strong as
resilient as they get my friend Paul
Pelosi falls down
and of course these are calculated
moments these are stage managed moments
but they are moments that are expected
and then of course as is often the case
because presidents want to make the case
that things are good under their
stewardship Joe Biden closing the
evening with pretty strong optimism
we're not powerless for the forces to
confront us
see the test of our time
we have to be the nation we've always
been at our best optimistic hopeful
forward-looking a nation of the braces a
light over dark hope over fear you need
to reduce the stability over chaos and
it went on from there so a good speech
overall the three real proposals
billionaire attacks increasing the tax
on stock BuyBacks and expanding the 35 a
month price cap on insulin many other
topics discussed Republicans
extraordinarily triggered and leading to
maybe the most disgusting State of the
Union response speech which I want to
talk about next
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are great having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
fifty percent off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below